Black Friday which has become somehow
more important than Thanksgiving itself
of course is the day after Thanksgiving
when every store on earth has sales that
you will not believe in you can get a
flat-screen TV for like 25 bucks and
that whole thing but of course there is
a price to pay and there are many videos
on YouTube that prove it
that's America because I love America
that is America that's why we went with
it
it looks like it's out of World War Z is
this just consumerism run rampant
I mean come on these guys they're trying
to get a flat-screen TV for $25 when
they're out of work
but even if it was a good economy people
love this stuff for some reason - I
think it's great I think commercialism
is fine look I'm all for pushing the
season having these stores open on
Thanksgiving Day I don't buy any of this
phony stuff that if you're not you know
closed on Thanksgiving Day you're not
Pro family baloney a lot of people eat
in the morning they want to shop in the
afternoon yeah when I say yeah my mom
and I that's our thing like you know
that's our bonding we don't have the big
traditional family it's just the two of
us we eat we we show our thanks and then
we bond family oriented style through
shopping do you do it on Thanksgiving
cuz now just in the last couple years
stores are actually starting to open on
Thanksgiving - it's not just stores and
open on Thanksgiving like you know you
forget something on the way to a
friend's house for or family dinner you
you want to buy something you get bored
after four hours I'm not a football guy
and I sit around watching football I
want to go out and shop and get some
stuff done I'm a Virgo I've also worked
in retail and and that's I hate it for
the people that are working that don't
want to be at work and then they don't
have an option to work on days that I
didn't want to work retail what you're
doing now I mean this is a message to
people they are giving you work you work
hard in retail you'll get a different
job I don't look come on this is America
you get to work if you're working four
jobs and one happens to be on
Thanksgiving you're getting paid but
isn't there something to be said for
just having a national day off like I
get it you want to shop and you want to
do that it's nice to keep the economy
going on but just to have a day just two
days a year maybe Thanksgiving Christmas
that's it we're pretty much everything
it's just shut down and we can stop this
endless I guess so but at this the same
time I feel like it's about choice and
it's about options you know and it's
like you know we're both saying for some
people that's their bonding I know for
all my family thanked Thanksgiving and
Christmas
day we do shopping and we do movies so
thank goodness somebody's you know
working the ticket booth yeah Chinese
work yeah we're helping the economy in
another way do you think this bodes
poorly when people in other countries
see this kind of thing because is there
any other country that a day of riots
for all kinds of other reasons probably
much more legitimate reasons but does
this make us look doubly stupid then
because then they're like look at those
Americans when they have riots it's
because they want to get you know a
microwave at half price no I think
they're jealous I think they look at us
and they say wouldn't we love to have an
economy that's booming where people are
rushing through to buy something
I mean economies around the world are
doing terribly they would kill for this
right like yes that consumerism at its
finest but I will say when you really do
the research these sales aren't all that
great no they're not that's what's crazy
I'm sure oh great you're just selling
serious yeah final thought on this what
do you make of like just the general
group mentality like when you see those
videos they're they're funny but people
literally get trampled someone got
killed
they got Walmart a couple years ago
pepper spray I mean all kinds of what is
it about that because I don't think it's
just about the deal I think there's some
other adrenaline yeah something else
going on I love to see it I let me see
the videos I love to see people like
rushing in and who gets it you know one
of the best things is those bridal God
when there's like a bridal sales and
those Brides are like rushing over
people those are fantastic you can't see
enough of those what would you do with
that right would you actually
participate or have you participated I
don't have where a wedding you know
maybe if it was the sale was right
I would pay somebody to wait in line for
me and then come in at the last minute
you pay somebody wait in line and go
from there